[Music]
all these people interested in stories
what are you nuts the Epicureans are
meeting around the corner by the way ah
all right they have free drinks now just
kidding okay so how to be a stoic
actually the title of the book that I'm
gonna be briefly talking to you about is
a handbook for new Stoics why would
anybody want to be a stoic and why don't
we need a new handbook since there's
plenty of really really good books that
were written in 2000 years ago well
first of all because they were read in
2000 years ago and so the language is
not exactly that accessible also we
learned a few things from science and
philosophy in the last 2,000 years not a
lot but enough to come up with a little
bit of an update on the basic concepts
but let me start out with why and why
would anybody be interested in this kind
of thing well stoicism is a philosophy
of life one of a number of philosophies
of life you probably have heard of
others Epicureans I just mentioned is
one Epicureanism Buddhism is another one
it may be a religion it may be a
philosophy of life in fact I don't think
there is much of a difference between
the two in some respects I think that a
philosophy of life has essentially two
components in metaphysics which is a
general account of how the world hangs
together how things work and an ethics
which is a general account of how we
should behave in that world right
the notion typically is that in order to
figure out how to behave in the world
you need to have to know something about
how the world actually works otherwise
you are liable to miss left to live a
life that it's not really in accordance
with with how things work so every
religion in the world is also a
philosophy of life I grew up Catholic
for instance and you do learn two things
you learn about a metaphysics you know
God created stuff and he basically
controls what's happening in the world
what do you believe that metaphysics or
not that's a different issue but it does
have a metaphysics and then of course
you go to church
on Sunday mornings to learn how to deal
with other people how to behave as a
decent human being and so on and so
forth so the differences between
different philosophies of life than
religions in my mind are actually
relatively minor there are a lot of
similarities between stoicism and
Buddhism for instance even epicurean is
not really that different once you get
into the details but they have enough
differences that different philosophies
or religions will speak to certain
people and not necessarily to others
that depends in part on your cultural
background on your personality on where
you are in life and cetera et cetera so
when I started getting into these kind
of stuff a few years ago I did explore a
number of possibilities I read a little
bit about Buddhism I read about
Epicureanism of course I knew about the
standard religions and nothing really
clicked and then all of a sudden one day
I saw of all things on my Twitter feed I
saw something sent help us celebrate
stoical week I said what the hell is
stoical week and why would anybody want
to celebrate it but I was curious
I got him vaguely remember the Stoics
from from high school and I signed up
and it immediately clicked right so soon
as I started reading epic taters Seneca
Marcus Aurelius is oh this guy is
actually talking to me in a way that I
understand and here we are five years
later I'm still talking about it
so let me so that's that's why we're
doing it it's everybody has a philosophy
of life whether they realize it or not
either because you inherited as your
religion when you grow up or your
philosophy as you go up or because you
still go through life with a certain
general understanding of how the world
works that's the metaphysics again and
you also presumably have some kind of
intuition at least of how to behave
toward other people and that's your
ethics whether you actually have it
spelled out and you thought about it or
not it's that's that's the difference
and the the bet that with my co-author
Greg Lopez we make in the book is that
it's better actually to know about this
stuff what you think about what it is
that you're doing and why you're doing
it rather than just wing it
for your life and for an entire life and
then you get to do your deathbed and say
oh crap could've done better there's no
do-over yeah it's pretty far as we know
so that's why now let me talk to you a
little bit about stoicism in particular
and then what I want to do is to give
you just give you so the the really
basic stuff and then actually like to
walk you through a couple the exercises
in the book because this book is very
practical it's got very little theory in
the brain in the beginning to get you
going but then it's actually 52
exercises which if you have enough
endurance you can go on for an entire
year to do one one per week if you don't
have that level of endurance so wherever
or at least you're not that committed at
the beginning because I understand that
so that's a hell of a lot commitment we
do provide a cheat sheet I begin at the
beginning we say okay here are the nine
crucial exercises you want to go through
and so you can just invest a few weeks
see if it works for you and if it
doesn't well you only wasted up twenty
bucks or something sorry
so first the basics stories started out
about the near the end of the fourth
century before the modern era in Athens
the guide that established the
philosophy was Xena of sytems you know
was actually a merchant and he lost
everything that he had in a shipwreck
right outside of Athens he made it to
the city and of course walk walk what
would be the first thing you did if you
just lost everything in life you walk to
a book store that's what he did and if
you walk to a book store what happens
well you obviously you hear the owner of
the bookstore reading out a book about
philosophy and in particular in that in
that case the memorabilia which is a
book by example about the life of
Socrates so Xena got like it was very
interested and he asked the the
booksellers is like where can I get me
one of these meaning a philosopher and
and the books bookseller said over there
there is one just walk in mine because
that was ancient Athens Athens you know
people were walking behind him chances
are that they were philosophers the guy
in question it's a different world you
know it was a different world the guy
question was credits of t-base it was a
cynic philosopher cynicism doesn't mean
what I mean didn't mean what it means
today in fact many interesting English
words cynic
skeptic stoic and epicurean don't mean
what they met in ancient Greece and that
that could be a whole interesting talk
right there but I'm not going to do it
now
so Xena started studying first with
kritis then with other teachers and
eventually he felt confident enough to
sort of start teaching on his own and he
started doing that in public in a place
called the store película which means
the painted porch right in the middle of
the market near the Agora in central
Athens and that's why the philosophy is
called stoicism because he started out
in the store so stores are where public
markets public colonnades
where people would gather so stores is
in from the beginning was forward the
people was they were interested in
talking to the people they were just
walking by as opposed to most of the
other schools which established
themselves in the suburbs outside of
Athens so that they wouldn't be bothered
by you know people unless they were
really interested so that's how it
started now the basic ideas are three
fundamentally there's one basic
assumption that comes with the
philosophy and then there are two major
ways of practicing it and so I'm going
to go briefly through that and then
we'll get to the exercises the basic
assumption of stoicism is that we should
live life according to nature
now before you run into the forest naked
and start hugging trees that's not what
it means there's nothing wrong with
doing that if you want to do it go ahead
but but that's not sources living
according to nature means that we should
take seriously human nature in order to
decide what kind of life you want to
live because otherwise we are in fact
human beings we're not lions we're not
chimpanzees were not something else so
there are certain things that work for
human beings because of the nature of
humanity or what it means to be human
now of course different people have
different ideas about what it means to
be human the old concept of human nature
is been under discussion in both science
and philosophy for literally 2,000 years
the Stoics had this notion however that
there are two fundamental components to
being human that Trump everything else
one is the where
my social animals we're not the only
social animals obviously there are
social other social primates that are
social insects and so on but we are
fundamentally social we can survive on
our own if we have to but even for long
periods of time but in fact we thrive
only in social groups we seek
recognition we seek affection we see
relationships with other people so that
is that is a fundamental component of a
good human life the second thing that
distinguishes human beings is the
ability to reason to a far greater
extent than any other species on earth
we can have a whole separate discussion
I'm a biologist we can have a whole
separate discussion about the extent to
which other species are capable of
reasoning or not but hey it's just us
here there I don't see any chimpanzee is
discussing philosophy at the moment so
we definitely have an ability to reason
far above em beyond anything else on
planet earth now whether we use it well
and we use it often that's a whole
different thing but we are capable of it
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at III TV
you